The basic functionality
of GCD is as follows.
We need to be able to create a queue,
either from scratch or
reuse an existing one.
Get the main queue and
also add a closure to an existing queue.
Grand Central Dispatch was
not written in SWF, but see.
Unlike SWF, C has no classes or objects.
So, Grand Central Dispatch
is made of functions and
types instead of classes and methods.
These functions and types have different
naming conventions than those used in
SWF, but they behave exactly
as if they were SWFcode.
First of all,
we need a type to represent queues.
That's dispatch_queue_t,
then we will need a function to
create a queue from scratch.
Dispatch_queue_create.
It takes two parameters, a name and the
type of the queue, serial or concurrent.
To specify serial,
just pass dispatch_queue_serial or nill.
IOS always gives each app four extra
queues on top of the name one.
These are called global queues.
We access those global queues with
a function, dispatch_get_global_queue.
The only difference between those
four queues is the priority or
how fast it will get
the attention of the CBU.
It's a good practice to avoid creating
queues when using an existing one is
enough.
We will use dispatch_get_
global_queue for that.
We also need a way to
obtain the main queue.
This is the queue that runs all your UI.
We will use the dispatch_get_main_queue
function for this.
Why we need this might not
be obvious right now, but
it will be as soon as we get
started with the sample app.
Last but not least, we need a way
of adding closures to the queue,
that's where dispatch_async comes in.
This function takes a queue and
a closure, it adds this closure to
the queue and then returns immediately.
The code inside the queue will run
sometime in the immediate future,
the exact time will depend
on how many closures already
waiting in the queue and
the priority of the queue.